good evening I'm Mike canet our Dean of
the Wisconsin School of Business and
it's my pleasure to welcome all of you
to our special interview this evening
with Daniel gross dan is one of the most
widely read financial and economic
writers working today is a senior editor
at Newsweek and he writes their regular
money culture column and he also
publishes a twice weekly column money
box for one of my favorite online
magazines slate magazine before joining
Newsweek in the spring of 2007 dan wrote
the economic view column for The New
York Times was a contributing writer to
New York and regular contributor to
magazines such as fortune wired New
Republic and also to Bloomberg News
Dan's a native of east lansing michigan
which gives him a lot of credibility
with us here in madison wisconsin
graduated from cornell university with
degrees in government in history holds
an am in american history from harvard
university he's the author of several
books including forbes greatest business
stories of all time which was a New York
Times bestseller in a finalist for the
Financial Times Lex award given to the
best business history book he also
authored Bull Run Wall Street the
Democrats in the new politics of
personal finance and pop why bubbles are
great for the economy which was
published in may of 2007 great something
we may want to revisit great timing dan
regularly appears in the media on CNBC
MSNBC and National Public Radio is a
participant in the World Economic Forum
and is a recipient of the National
headliners award for best magazine
column of 2008 it is a pleasure to have
you with us dan thank you for taking the
time to visit the University of
Wisconsin well it's a great pleasure to
be here to get away from New York turn
off CNBC and view some of the real
economy for a change the non-financial
economy or yeah the real economy as we
see it I couldn't agree more it's I you
know it's the opposite for me I get to
New York about six or seven times a year
for board meetings or other alumni event
inson I have to say I was out there for
a board meeting at the end of September
and it was probably the most depressing
visit I have ever had to New York by
miles because I think at that point
people had no idea where the bottom was
and you know i'm not sure we do now but
at least the last few months feels like
we've gained a little bit of stability
before we go any further dan as you all
know just recently published his new
book dumb money how the greatest
financial minds bankrupt the nation and
i thought we could start by having you
autograph my copy of dumb money oh this
is my amazon kindle a cassette that's
going to be hard dan gave me a physical
copy of his book so maybe you could
autograph this one for okay this means
once it's signed that on ebay it goes
for fifty cents instead of a dollar okay
there's some there's some economic
listen we're by the proximity to the
author decreases the value so let's
start talking a little bit about how you
got into writing about the economy
because in your background study
government history were in a ph.d
program in history and then admittedly
your books are about recent economic
history but your bead is really
economics how did you find your way into
that sure well my first job out of
college was at the New Republic magazine
which was writing about politics I went
back to graduate school from the ph.d
program I figured I would do two years
and see how I felt I was freelancing
throughout that period and one of the
things I did aside from grading papers
and TN was there's a volume called the
International directory of company
histories it was like three thousand
word histories of 20,000 different
companies and let saw do one of these a
month or so to make some extra money so
I started learning a little bit about
business history and and what different
companies were doing I had not been a
when I read The Wall Street Journal i
read the politics section some of 92 i
wanted to get out of graduate school i
passed my oral exams but the thought of
doing a dissertation made me break out
into cold sweat so I wanted to try new
york I'd been in Washington and of
course most the jobs in New York and
financial
media was a pretty deep media recession
at the time so I was going around i had
my contacts and my clips and people kept
saying you know if you go to bloomberg
they'll hire you in a minute look great
what's Bloomberg and Bloomberg you know
the new sir at the time was about 15
people and I was hired for what is quite
possibly the worst job in journalism
this is before the internet and we had
you know 15 or 20 reporters and the
Bloomberg was this proprietary box that
sat on brokers desks and they needed to
have any money news that could move a
stock or the market into that box by 8am
so our job was coming at four in the
morning take the wall street journal in
New York Times and other financial
publications find articles that our
reporters had missed which was a lot of
them and summarize them in three
sentences say you know the wall street
journal reported this and then add a
sentence of proprietary Bloomberg
content you know something about their
stock price or something zap it out over
the wire so that when a blue an author
came I'm trying to broker came in at
seven thirty they knew what was what so
that gave me so big they spent a lot of
time just reading financial publications
that was my first sort of education if
you will the school of hard knocks so
when you read about the economy I'm
curious who do you pay attention to I
mean other economists that you find
useful are there business journalists
that you follow I'm just wondering you
know what does a person like you track
so every day New York Times Wall Street
Journal Financial Times Washington Post
look at and you know the Economist
fortune Businessweek etc there are a
bunch of great economic bloggers brad
delong the University of California
Berkeley Paul Krugman who in addition to
writing the column has a blog Greg
Mankiw from Harvard slightly different
perspective but very instructive Larry
Summers was doing a great column in The
Financial Times it was probably some of
the best writing on the financial
meltdown
people I talked to an interview you know
nouriel roubini and the RG e monitor
which they put out has a great deal of
stuff ken rogoff from harvard and then
there are a lot of good very lucid wall
street at well not as many but david
rosenberg of merrill lynch and you know
as I'm able to get a lot of kind of
research zap to me HSBC out of London
has a great team that writes about the
US and global economics guy named
Stephen King and you know we're just
very fortunate to be in this world where
there's so much stuff out there and that
because you remember the press you get a
lot of stuff zapped to you that other
people have to pay a lot of money for
one of my favorites is a grants interest
rate observer it's a weekly magazine
which is just it's where I learned about
CDOs and things like that in 2005 way
ahead of the curve so that's a great
list actually I couldn't agree more i
mean a lot of those names you mentioned
that i'm familiar with from the
economics profession are people that
because of the internet you can follow
their thoughts much more regular basis
than you know happening to see them at a
conference every fourth or something
that's what's really changed i think
made modern media much more competitive
idea marketplace you know your book for
those who haven't read it is actually
very informative but it's also pretty
humorous funny and spots you take a lot
of I think playful shots that at actors
and in things that have happened in the
economy how do you strike that balance
between humor and substance when you're
writing about the economy well you know
it hasn't been all that funny in the
past couple years but you know I write
for a pretty broad audience Newsweek we
have a circulation of three million you
know in theory when you're writing
online you're writing for a what could
be an infinite audience but what usually
is a much smaller one but i think the
use of sort of humor pop culture
references it's a way of drawing people
in
when you are writing for Newsweek or for
slate you are to a degree writing for a
non-business audience right you are
trying to explain demystify and there's
a kind of didactic way of doing that
this is what a CDO is they put these
things together and carve them up in two
tranches and there's a more creative way
of doing that which could be more
engaging by saying you know they this is
like what people do with clams where
some people like the strips and some
people like the bellies and some people
I can fry and some people like them
steamed and you know so I think your
challenge is in a environment where
there's so much out there having a
trying to have a distinctive voice but
also trying to draw people in who are
not sort of reading it for work or who
may not see their natural readers and
then at the same time trying to write it
at such a level that professionals might
also get something out here well I think
you do a great job of it I think and you
also pull out some of the all-time great
quotes about the financial crisis and
market meltdown bonner had a great quote
I think about the stimulus package or
dark yeah anyway let's get into the
themes of the book the title refers to
the greatest financial minds that
bankrupt in the nation and it reminds me
of an old skid on Saturday Night Live
called I ruined it for everybody and and
that was a skid about a talk show where
the host would invite on guests whose
behavior had been so egregious it
destroyed an entire social convention so
for example a guest might be the first
hitchhiker that ever murdered the person
that picked him up you know that was
that was the day that hitchhiking died
you know and other social conventions
have those problems and of course
there's a lot of potentially valuable
social conventions that might have been
ruined here investment banking as we
know it financial innovation like
securitization or subprime lending maybe
I'm being generous calling it financial
innovations they have been captured by
the economics and in banking professions
but many of these conventions really do
have value but recent events are going
to make it probably difficult for them
to resume
at least in their prior forms so if
you're the host of today's I ruined it
for everybody and it's about the recent
financial crisis who are your three
guests who do you want to drink huh you
only get three give me your top three
we'll we'll go for more and this is the
child because the thing that's so
amazing about this crisis and you know I
lived through and reported on the.com
boom in the 90s and a lot of those
companies that came from nowhere and
became 10 billion dollar companies then
crash were founded by no offense guys
kids they were recent graduates of
college who were wearing flip-flops and
who had never lived through a business
cycle and never run anything and so was
it any great surprise that a lot of
these pets calm and this calm crashed
thing about this decade is that this was
the production of 50 60 and 70 year old
men who had lived through the 87 market
crash and man who ran gigantic
institutions who had lived through ups
and downs who had all this collective
wisdom who had demonstrated great
capabilities in times of crisis in the
90s and yet somehow it didn't prevent
them from really screwing things up in
the in the worst possible imagining so
the first person I love I would be
Greenspan which you know it's very easy
to look at him and say he he destroyed
all this stuff you have to weigh it
against I think if he had not taken this
final term for the greatest central
banker in history ever among them or the
luckiest given what we've learned that
was luck but he was very he was also he
was good you know he comes in 87 he gets
us through that market crash in the 90s
he was very constructive as being kind
of a counterweight on encouraging the
Clintons to be more conservative fiscal
policy he had a hunch about the impact
of globalization and what that would do
to productivity and inflation and kind
of push the pedal to the metal where the
evidence wasn't there he turned out to
be right dot-com bubble was sort of bad
but in retrospect it was sort of a blip
he got
through we had a brief recession and we
came out of 90 911 with our economy and
institution attack so if he had kind of
cut it off you would have said he's a
genius and he was the maestro and he did
over here duh you roll it forward and
it's clear and I think you know it's
clear to some people at time that he
took interest rates very low and left
them too low for too long a time he was
a member of the committee to save the
world in the 90s and Time magazine had
that cover this decade he was a member
of the committee that set the world on
fire right the proliferation of cheap
money certainly one of the articulation
helped light speculative booms in not
just housing and credit but also
commodities etc he was a voice against
and you really saw I think this
combination of him being in office with
a conservative Republican presidential
administration where instead of being in
counterweight he just said have said you
want to cut taxes massively boom okay
and you know he had so much moral
authority that if he had said boo about
anything they did it would have put the
brakes on it you want a Medicare
entitlement program that cost who knows
how many trillion yeah okay capital gain
suck they wouldn't get more taxes
spending etc etc and no time did he
stand up and say this is fiscal madness
so I would dig him for that his belief
in the ability of markets to be more
efficient which made a lot of sense in
the 90s it made sense but it pushed him
to say we won't and cannot regulate
credit default swaps right these are
just March full of rational actors they
do things that make sense this is just
another form of that and there's also
evidence that people inside the fed at
Gramlich we're coming and saying this
subprime stuff is out of control we're
in charge of regulating some aspects of
banking we should be looking more
closely and discouraging these sorts of
things the evidence seems to suggest
that he shunted that aside so that's the
first guess he can sit at the head of
the table he got day for a while by
himself
the second you have to get someone from
the sort of the shadow banking mortgage
industry right these non-bank lenders
that instead of taking deposits and
lending went to Wall Street raised
Google's of capital and then kind of
test brokers to go out and find people
so Angelo Mozilo countrywide financial
became the biggest non-bank mortgage
lender hit stores right these were
financial products they were selling
them like crazy sub prime prime you name
it that company failed bank of america
took them over it didn't exactly a large
cost from the taxpayer but he was really
emblematic you know he was the sort of
perpetual eat and I the big promoter of
the industry and the third I think I'd
have to split it between say Chuck
prints and the former CEO of Citigroup
and steve schwarzman because we've had a
Washington person policy we have
California person sort of non-bank
lending and you have to have the Wall
Street representatives schwartzman
representative the CEO Blackstone this
kind of one things I read about my book
is that we like to think this is this
originated in subprime and it had a lot
to do with housing that people in
corporate lending did the exact same
stuff they securitize the loans they
they lowered their guard they went to
insane amounts of leverage and he was
the sort of you know this is the biggest
private equity firm they sold shares to
the public sure right at the top and
then chuck prince who was the CEO of
citigroup he was a lawyer who was
brought in to kind of clean up after the
90s excesses and what does he do he
closed and presides over a series of
lending access is greater than anything
they did in the 90s professed not to
really understand what a CDO was and all
this stuff it couldn't be bothered with
that and he had the best to me the line
that most epitomizes the kind of upside
down world which we were in which is the
summer of two thousand seven it's clear
you know all this crazy lending to
private equity deals 40 billion 30
billion 20 billion buying companies with
no money down it's clear the cycle is
down shifting someone said why are you
doing this and he said well as long as
the music is playing you have to keep
dancing we're still dancing
so bank with the two trillion dollar
balance sheet should be the most
powerful bank in the world and he was
sort of a puppet on the string of you
know private equity people and just
anytime they whatever they wanted he had
to give them and he had he felt like he
had no choice in the matter never mind
his fiduciary duty his duty as a citizen
his duty as an employer of 300,000
people just shovel the money out the
door so those would be my my invites
that's a pretty good list and I'm sure
it gets difficult you know at that point
there's probably other good candidates
but let's leave it at that we can come
back and do some mop-up duty later if we
need to dumb money actually
distinguishes between three stages of
the financial crisis and your terms
there's the period of cheap money the
period of dumb money and then the period
of dumber money can you tell us a little
bit about that progression and sure kind
of how you explain the crisis through
those chats so there have cheap money I
starts sort of at nine eleven and goes
through 04 where you have Greenspan twin
recession Fed lowers rates Greenspan
reacts to 911 by got to get the economy
moving in takes rates and he takes the
federal funds rate down to one percent
and leaves it there right so the
short-term rates are low is low can be
at the same time we have this expanding
trade deficit we're buying all our
plastic goods from China and all our
petroleum from the Persian Gulf so we're
sending all these dollars overseas and
how do those dollars come back to our
shores well we're not really pleased
about the Chinese buying stocks or
assets of companies this is the Chinese
government we don't want the government
of Kuwait and Dubai to be buying
American companies in fact when a
company affiliated with the Dubai
government bought ports world which
control the Port of Baltimore Congress
went nuts so the safest thing for them
to buy with government bonds if they
wanted a little more yield Fannie and
Freddie bonds which were had the implied
guarantee so you have all this money
perpetually being recycled into the long
end of the yield curve bringing interest
rates down so cheap money and it goes
into housing which is the most leverage
product or purchase
people make and it was actually very
good that we have this nice housing boom
in 02 03 04 because our economy continue
to lose jobs after the recession ended
and we think about jobs that are created
by housing architects decorators
construction people insurance agent
mortgage broker blue collar white collar
no collar they're all local they're all
domestic by definition from November 01
through the spring of 05 something like
forty percent of the private sector jobs
created were in housing so this was all
to the good and rising home values
allowed the shadow banking system to
come in and say let's tap into that home
equity and give you some consumer
spending money so Greenspan did a paper
with another guy at the Fed that showed
you know mortgage equity withdrawal
which is the cash we're extracting from
refinancing and home equity was up to
like nine percent of consumer spending
in 05 the peak so this is all pretty
benign though right housing prices were
going people were like people were
feeling wealthier the economy was
growing again we start to add jobs well
all good things come to an end and 04
Greenspan starts to take rates up one we
go from one to five and a quarter over a
two-year period long-term rates start to
back up because people are worried about
inflation and normally the housing
market in response to that would cool
off because it makes price of money gets
more expensive but what we got in the
era of dumb money was innovation which
was go from a 30-year fixed two
adjustable rape go from adjustable rate
to a negative amortization loan everyone
starts lowering their standards lowering
their guard because the you know
everybody's motivated by fees no one's
holding on to these loans anymore they
want to chop them up and securitize that
convinced ourselves that through
securitization we spread risk and the
people who buy the risk in the form the
boz can use derivatives to heads to the
risk and so the overriding you know if
you talk to mortgage brokers it was all
about getting someone into the house
being able to make the first payment and
not worrying about what happened
afterwards so have these teaser rates
you had you know low doc loans no doc
loans and the final ninja loans which no
income no job no assets no problem
and then what sets in and in these sort
of stages of a bubbles what I call pro
forma disease where people look back and
they say the last three years look like
this grew at ten percent there for the
next five years are going to go like
that and you can invest in borrow
accordingly so people started to think
like that about housing so why not buy a
house with no money down if it's always
going to go up you can just flip it and
you can just refinance your way out of
trouble so this mentality starts to set
settle in in 04 05 that's the period of
dumb money then we move on in 06 housing
Peaks starts to go down so the basic
tenant of this whole game that housing
prices will always rise is no longer
true and yet people are still engaging
in this activity so this is the era of
dumber money and this the period when it
crosses over from housing and subprime
into corporate commercial real estate
lending other types of lending and so
we're now seeing this the fallout
housing starts to go bad no 7 2009 is
when commercial real estate starts to go
bad mm-hmm so the Dumber money is I
guess not drawing the lesson when the
pro formas were shown to be wrong and
people still continued on you know it's
funny I I haven't read pop why bubbles
are great for the economy but it's it's
funny to me that you'd written that
around the time all this was going on
and so what's the premise of that book
and well this goes back to my you know
having studied history and in summer oh
no no one when the fiber-optic meltdown
happened and there was this great
tendency to declare the whole thing was
a con right right we've been scammed
diluted and you look back and what
happened with the Telegraph and the
railroad the exact same thing the exact
same cycle and the exact same rhetoric
people latched onto this new technology
and new economic assumptions they
thought the technology would change the
economic assumptions you see people
talking about the Telegraph basically
saying that you know we're not going to
have inventory problems anymore because
people have instant communication right
we're going to do away with the business
cycle which is what they said about the
internet sure people thought the
internet was going to usher in a world
of sort of
world peace because everybody would be
able to communicate they said the same
thing about the Telegraph and the same
cycle happy that people who put the
telegraph wires all went bankrupt people
who built the railroads in the 1880s we
had major excess capacity in 1894
one-third of railroads were bankrupt but
we look at those episodes you know that
that's when sort of the books get
commissioned about the demise of Enron
but you know when you take a longer view
that's only half the story because we
didn't tear up the Telegraph and we
didn't tear up the railroads and we
didn't tear up the fiber-optic cable and
in fact what you got it as a result of
this bubble was a integrated nationwide
system that had become suddenly cheap
right and when you get a new capital
structure behind it you now have a
pervasive new infrastructure and the
genius of Americans is that we figure
out what to do with that so all the
Telegraph companies kind of go bust you
get a kind of a few companies that end
up surviving and owning but you get
Western Union the concept of sending
money by wire what you couldn't do in
the in the at the height of the bubble
because the system's didn't connect with
each other but now you could that
business is still around you got the
associated press these papers band
together and they buy capacity in bulk
you had this is when the Chicago Board
of Trade got going because you realize
now you can have a national market for
information it was only because of that
excess building that it rolled out that
quickly with railroads before if you are
retailer your customer base was people
who could walk to your store now that
railroad went everywhere Chicago was the
hub it's no secret it's no mystery why
Sears Roebuck and Montgomery Ward
invented mail-order retailing out of
Chicago because they could reach anybody
in two days and so when you look at the
Sears catalog it's like looking at
amazon.com today this world of goods
that were available the people sure
because of that so these bubbles all had
some lasting infrastructure whether they
leave behind behind a new commercial
infrastructure or a new technology that
others can use for new types of
businesses that were not imagined during
the bubble that's when they're
beneficial so look let's go back to the
calm so 2001
Crossing worldcom all these are going
bankrupt five percent of the fiber optic
cable was in use so the price of
everything associated with the internet
office space in San Francisco
programming talent aeron chairs plummets
right mm-hmm in addition during bubbles
we built this commercial infrastructure
and we also build what I call the mental
infrastructure which is all this money
is spent on hype and promotion trying to
get people to do things differently so
in the 90s you know if you signed up for
an ameritrade account they would give
you four hundred dollars and they're all
these kind of crazy discounting going on
a lot of businesses ran on negative
margins because they wanted to get
people in the habit of buying books and
stocks and things online so those
companies may fail but that mental
infrastructure stays so when you have
this combination of pervasive or
something close to pervasive broadband
and an installed base of users of 5060
million however many who are comfortable
doing things online you come along in
2002 and for nothing you can build a
business with great scale for very
little capital so this is when Google
attains critical mass youtube myspace
you know all the web two point O
companies were built kind of get
critical mass in 0203 on the wreckage of
that bubble and had we you know the
difference between the US and Europe is
very instructive because there they get
a new technology and the government gets
involved in early stage and they slowly
rashly stream the telegraph wire from
town to town and then the railroads and
fiber optic and so you don't get this
messy frenzy but you also don't get that
and how you innovation and all the
spin-offs so I think this is the sort of
price we pay for getting a lot of this
stuff because we our system does not
tolerate and we don't want the kind of
government to get involved the
government always helps provides
incentives it provides tax breaks
provides a nudge but we don't want the
government to say we're going to have
broadband now and this is how we're
going to do it sure it's better to give
some incentives and let the private
sector go nuts doing it because it's
messy it creates losses but the benefits
get pretty widely distributed yeah you
know it's interesting to contrast those
two bubble periods you know and you were
saying earlier you know who could fault
the young kid
and flip flops who built the dot-com
economy they didn't know what they were
doing and I would say I mean actually
they're the they're the great people in
the story you know they were the
innovators and they built a lot of these
new companies and it I would argue it
was really the same group of people who
caused the bubble because you needed the
investment community to buy in and then
somehow collectively overvalue these
companies I mean the kids running the
company weren't in a position to create
the bubble they didn't have the money to
drive the share prices up the way they
went up so i would say that bubble was
in a different sort of way again just a
huge wealth transfer from one set of
investors to insiders who were smart
enough to get out early enough and we
probably both know plenty who did and it
is kind of interesting you know the
people that I've known that made a lot
of money on companies that later on
proved not to be worth very much you
know yeah they feel good about what they
have but they also feel like they still
have something to prove because I hope
they know sure they sort of got a
windfall that really they didn't deserve
because the company now there's no
question the it takes Wall Street to
create a bubble that's right and so in
in the more recent case you know again
it's it's the investment community that
drove up the value of a lot of these
assets they were being sold by people
there was I would argue there will be
some lasting benefits so what's the
thing that we built too much of housing
and you know house prices are going to
come down now if you're a pre-existing
homeowner you may not like that but if
you're somebody who needs to buy into
the housing market in the future well
there's the lasting innovation from this
episode or one of them is there anything
in the financial innovation that you
think will last because I think it's too
easy to dismiss finance as something
that isn't value-added because you can't
touch it or but really you know we've
come a long way obviously over history
my parents bought their house with cash
they think I'm a lunatic because I have
a mortgage for you know hundred thousand
dollars but you know I think they should
have been in their house a lot sooner
than they ever were so what will come
out of this as the innovation that you
know has durable value well you look a
few things you look at some of the
services that were built up like Zillow
or domain
if you ever use those which are
enormously beneficial for consumers and
one of the crazy things about housing
was this market that everybody
participates in but information was kept
so close to shell right you know the
listing service and only the brokers
knew what the prices were and what the
people had paid for them well now you
can go and you can find out you can use
it for sort of proving you meet someone
at a party then you can go and figure
out how much they paid and if you want
you can go in town hall and see how much
debt they have on their house right
that's enormously I didn't know that you
can go down to town well maybe you can't
hear but I think generally in there's a
great blog called Irvine housing block
okay well this guy every day puts up a
property and kind of charts you know
someone bought it for 500 then they took
a HELOC for 350 and now you know and
documents what happened so you can get
that information it's the epicenter of a
lot of the house education yeah so that
is enormously empowering as a consumer
and when you think about housing of this
market it's the biggest thing anybody
ever buys and a lot of inefficiencies
built in and a lot of lack of
information flow in theory empowering
people with more information will make
them better and smarter consumer so I
don't think that goes away and also I
think you know when we talk about mental
and infrastructure and sort of mindset
you know not so much the idea of
flipping condos with no money down but
this whole refinancing culture I mean
for everybody who got bird refinancing
you could point to five or six people
who refinance from a fix to a fix to a
fix and save themselves tens hundreds of
thousands of dollars over and that's
enormously beneficial that's a big
contributor to consumer spending and
we're seeing it now huge volumes of
refinancing people have been trained to
sort of watch interest rates to read a
motivation table and the systems that
enable us to do that cheaply
underwriting systems credit score
whatever those things are are in place
although Fannie and Freddie are now sort
of the government doing it but there's
this a lot of that activity going on I
think that mentality sticks around yeah
so making people smarter consumers of
housing and sort of smarter owners
and smarter investors may be mean what's
the future of mortgage-backed securities
and maybe the credit default swap market
I mean is there anything good to be said
about those markets and will there be
some long-term you know I saw that with
standardization I think people are i
spoke at asset-backed securities
conference in the fall of 07 and they
were no pretty down in the dumps and I
don't think they had the conference this
year there's one guy what a one guy came
up and said I think it's not good to
have that many depression which is going
to be down eighty percent next year and
they are like wani and issuance was done
eighty percent the next year I think
what we forgot was that securitization
is a tool you know it wasn't the the
algorithm that guaranteed you make money
it was like a wrench I was a little more
complicated than a wrench but admittedly
any you know so in the hands of a
skilled craftsperson who was careful
with their handiwork it's a great tool
in the hands of a reckless person you
could destroy a lot of things with it
and so I think that's what I don't think
the the fact that a lot of bombs that
were issued defaulted is a is it means
securitization doesn't work or is a bad
idea I still think it's a great idea you
just have to do it a little better right
you have to do it maybe maybe the person
who's doing the issuing and the
underwriting you know keep some skin in
the game maybe I start doing covered
bonds like they do in Europe and that
that's securitization that works quite
well so i think we are people if they
have been wanting to write it off are
sort of too quick to do it with credit
default swaps again great idea but when
you the biggest rider credit default
swaps was AIG and now you want to call
this fraud or stupidity they had no
intention of paying off their claims
right because if they had any intention
of paying off the cleanse they would
have put money aside it would have been
well they might have priced there at a
level that would have been rational
instead more spray collected a few
premiums spent it on other stuff and
compensation and didn't put any money
aside so that was you know Las Vegas
bookies without the juice exactly so
Christine
is room for someone to issue credit
default swap who wants to run it like an
insurance business and not like a a
hedge fund right yeah one of the
interesting things in this you know I
think it was really the misalignment of
incentives that you're getting at where
people are making money simply on the
deal flow the transactions and they
don't have any skin in the game and I
guess what shocked me at the end of it
all I was kind of figuring that the
investment banks that were bundling
stuff up and selling it we're really
selling at all and of course they were
holding thirty or thirty-five percent of
a lot of the the material they created
so they actually did have skin in the
game which is I think a bigger
indictment their ability someone that
was reluctant they they had amassed a
certain amount of stuff and then the
wheel yeah that's true stop to make I
learn about the door but they also had
internal proprietary Jack that we're
training this stuff and so had pretty
big positions themselves yeah so that
was interesting well you know you you
confessed the other day you had a little
debate in your in your column about with
yourself about whether bankers are
economists were the bigger villains in
this and Dan was quick to ask me when he
told me about this you're not an
economist are well actually I at least
used to be I don't know if I could call
myself that today but where do you come
down on that I mean did the economics
profession writ large really miss this
and how was what how would you grade out
the academic economists or government
well so the bankers really screwed it up
okay these guys were paid more than
anybody they had more social political
cultural incentive to preserve their
capital and their institutions than
anybody else and they they failed so
miserably that not only did they blow up
anybody who touched them financially but
they inflicted this massive costs on the
taxpayers what do you think about the
thing is we won't be able to do as a
nation yeah because of this it's just
it's mind-boggling and you know they're
they're getting they're sort of just
reward in the sense that they are being
shunned and halt before Congress and
yelled at etc so yeah the consensus may
be getting a few unjust rewards too long
right things we won't get back yeah
so you know sort of baked in the cake
that the bankers were the bad actors
here and and mess things up but they
couldn't have done it I think without
you know I focus a lot on kind of the
culture of business and the mindset and
the way stories get told in the media
and their economists were really
essential we didn't take our cues about
what goes on in the world from you know
ken lewis at the bank of america but we
did take our cues from alan greenspan he
told people in two thousand or that it
made more sense to have an adjustable
rate mortgage right when he was about to
start raising rates that's pretty bad
advice and and sort of beyond his
purview some of the other things you
know there was this whole debate do we
have a savings glut are we too much sure
yet that was a economist were leading
the discussion of that there were a lot
of wall street economists not all but
some who were actually captive and would
be going on CNBC and saying all these
assets are fine and you know that we
don't need to save because the markets
doing the saving for us there's a lot of
kind of post hoc justification to make
what seemed to be a rational movements
seem rational and where other places you
looked there were economists who were
doing the ratifying the model that AIG
used to write its credit default swaps
was cooked up by an economist and we
know that some of these models they use
for traveling that they only fed data in
for the previous five years previous
five years there were no default so what
were you going to get the chief
economist of the national association of
realtors came out with a book in 05
saying the housing boom won't bust this
is the best time possible to buy houses
so people kind of brandishing their
professional training economist they
were more disinterested we're 90 bankers
you can't take them Sir newsletter entry
barriers as a profession I guess ya know
some of these economists are conflicted
of course right the national association
of realtors Rimes what's he going to say
right what's a wall street economist
going to
but we know that we know we can't trust
bankers they're all about just getting
money they're not intellectuals they're
not seeing their studying things but
when you had economist who were
ratifying some of the stuff I think it's
sort of carried a little more weight yes
certainly people who didn't have an
inherent conflict who were ratifying it
much you know I would cut myself among
them I mean I'll be the first to say
right in thinking about the low savings
rate and the decline of the savings rate
I'll be the first to say hey savings
rates were high in the 70s and 80s
because people were so pessimistic right
the real return on the S&P from 1970 to
nineteen eighty four minus fifty percent
well that'll get your attention and you
will save a lot well from 1984 you know
you fast forward to 2010 and even after
the correction in 2001 I mean even today
right over the last 25 years the real
return on the SP is plus 250 250 percent
mean that's not bad so I think you can
say it's an ex post rationalization of a
low saving rate but if people are
looking at their 401k and there you know
the value of their real estate how can
you not take that information into
account when you decide how much more do
I really need to save so you know and I
guess you know I do take some issue you
know should the u.s. current account
balance be 0 I wouldn't think so I mean
I I still think that we are the country
that created the new economy industries
it was an attractive market for foreign
investors to buy into what are we going
to take in exchange for that we chose to
buy their goods and services rather than
by their assets which I probably makes
some sense so I think certainly things
were too frothy but it's not as simple
as people want to make it sound like
we'd all collectively lost our minds and
were you know I think you know the thing
with thee because I worked for many
years several years I edited a magazine
for a another business school I worked a
lot with economists I did the economic
view column new york times where we can
say the stern school of business there
you go it's okay they wrote a great book
on the crisis too and i spent a lot of
time when I
did the column for new types talking to
professional economists who are smart
generally smart dispassionate
intelligent intellectually curious and
so you know i think we probably expected
more from them than from you so if you
put up you take like AIG had on its
board of directors you know people like
Richard Holbrooke former Secretary of
State I don't expect him to be aware of
what's going on in that country ahead
Martin Feldstein one the greatest living
economist head of the nber he was on
that board for 21 years it was on the
risk committee I believe now I would
like to think that if you showed him
what AIG financial products was doing he
would have looked at it in 10 minutes
and said this is madness mm-hmm there's
no evidence that he did Zoe there's
maybe a double standard where we expect
some of these well-placed economists
Henry Calvin was on the board of Lehman
Brothers now some of the people on
Lehman Brothers bored out to lunch as
you you're on corporate boards you know
there are people who had value and there
are people who are there because there's
a little odd ones out to lunch now yeah
but they're people are there who are
there because of their professional
capabilities right people there who are
not there from the political world or
their celebrity or you know for whatever
reason so he was on the head of the risk
committee at Lehman Brothers this is a
company that had 650 billion dollars in
debt and leverage of 32 1 now you can
understand why an investment banker
would would do that this is how they get
paid but it seems to me someone
economist with this deep and experience
of that would look at that and and after
five minutes would say this doesn't
there's a lot of stuff that could go
wrong yet a job of the directs a
question of how much the directors are
able to look at and process in in you
know what is the reasonable amount of
time I mean really first and foremost
you're there to evaluate the CEO
performance succession planning things
like that and how deeply they dig into
the different aspects of the business I
think you're right about AIG their
financial products division was
exploding and generating so much value
that you'd think they'd
into what was behind that a little bit
more so that's fair well I'm actually
you know the list of economist that you
said you read I think that's a group of
people you get pretty good insights from
and I think you know they they represent
the profession well so but it's true you
know you're going to get a lot of
diverging views out there I mean make
you would would see things very
differently than Joe Stiglitz but
they're both pretty smart people
absolutely at some point you know
economics becomes you know there's value
judgment intertwined and it's it's hard
to say who's right and who's wrong how
do you think the Obama team has been
handling the economy since they've taken
over what sort of grades would you give
to Geithner summers let's say Bernanke
even though he's not really an Obama
team member and Obama himself how do you
how do you feel there well I think the
only you know only fair grade is
incomplete surest point yeah what uh
give the midterm you know Victor it's
just the midterm grade they had the
first exam how did they come out of the
gate b-minus b-minus one of the what's
the median grade in your class what we
got to know are you tough grader or you
know sounds pretty tough by emma is
pretty tough grader yeah okay be hard to
find a group that you know in recent
history that you've given a to I they
were pretty Syrian out sure Nixon Carter
those are those are d's and f's so for
grading on a curve I guess they're at
the upper end you know because these
people were out of power for so long
they spent a lot of time talking to
journalists and so I know pretty much
all the members of the economic team a
lot of them actually were contributors
to slate to high regard for them
personally I'm you know it met and
interviewed guy throw in a couple
occasions again high regard and you know
one of the things about our sort of
media world and the political world is
the way we process reputation so quickly
you're either you know you're a winner
you're the smartest guy in the room that
near that you know a week later and of
course no one has ever as smart as they
are at the P course they're the same
person
reality over time it kind of evens out
and I think you saw this with gartner in
particular where it's not that he people
thought he was so great but they're just
concluding after a week or two that he's
dumb stupid yeah yeah what like the
career up to that point meant nothing it
was two weeks and yeah so yeah I'm I
guess I'm a little like to say these
people are suddenly a bunch of idiots
the other thing is that the the degree
of difficulty of the text they have is
off the charts we haven't had anything
like this in quite some time and there
are yet to me that I usually know what I
think about something after reading a
fair amount talking to a few people some
of the biggest issues what to do with
Citigroup let's do with AIG these are
issues where you would take people I
think like brad delong Paul Krugman they
agree on ninety-eight percent of things
but on stupid unlike the bail out there
polar opposite right so and and sort of
Italy so so what are you to make what is
a mere mortal like me to make of that
where the people sort of you trust and
rely on who you feel like you're in
general in tune with their worldview and
all of a sudden they are poles apart
right so it that also makes it very hard
to evaluate because it's I would you
know I think they should be what I would
fault them is not being tougher with the
banks a Citigroup it is tomorrow mind is
not a business anymore yes it's a zombie
and there's not much hope for the equity
and yet they act like they're a bank so
somebody has to give them the message
that they're not going to be there is no
Citigroup anymore and there shouldn't be
one in a few years now so the answer is
okay nationalize it well who's going to
run it and given this climate who are
you going to sell these pieces to
because there aren't a lot of buyers of
gigantic things like this and if
Citigroup is under the federal umbrella
then our people is it then I'm going to
go compete against healthy banks with
this advantage of the market will think
it has a government you know people are
you saying AIG that they are going out
and undercutting the all states of the
world because
have access to sort of cheaper capital
so it's not as simple that people say
let them fail nationalize I mean these
are all it brings enormous complication
so I guess I'm jealous that giggle it's
was in Washington today they say let him
fail right well it's easy for him to say
since he doesn't have to yeah clean up
the mess so these are genuinely and I
think you run into this in policy
there's some issues that seem to be easy
calls should we do X or Y and there are
some that are generally difficult and
challenging calls and I think we've got
five or six of those right now so doing
the best they can but I would like them
I think they need for both political and
for reasons of justice and I think just
as a matter of policy to be less mindful
of Wall Street's prerogatives that's
that's what I've flown a lot of your
work and I think I would agree with that
you know I think some of what you're
talking about these discrepancies that
we see between people who politically
have very similar views and they're
trained economist like the long and
Krugman it just points out something
that I think a lot of people don't
appreciate and that is we really don't
have very much data about economies you
know I mean you think we have a lot of
data on the US economy but the economy
right now and the problems we face are
so different than even anything we had
the 1970s as to almost make that period
useless from the standpoint of assessing
you know what are you going to do with
this problem right you can look at other
countries experiences but still the
institutional structure is different
there's been all this financial
innovation connections between countries
are much tighter than they were before
so a lot of the old analysis is really
rendered useless and then you know we're
is also this also gets into why if you
look back at this decade we were told
that if we did certain things to taxes
that certain things would follow and
certain those certain things did not
follow in other words
our economy grew median income didn't
and all sorts of reasons why but what I
think that in this age sort of ideology
for economists is now pretty useless
because the the shape of the world the
globe's economic geography we was never
static but the pace of change is so
rapid that what you thought the impact
of something in 1992 would have been is
so far beyond what it'll be today
because dude the nineties you didn't
have China growing at ten percent a year
or India growing at eight percent a year
and the way that commodity prices have
been paying around and the things are
there you know we're still the biggest
economy but we don't we turn the
direction anymore and that should append
a lot of what you think about what doing
things in this in the u.s. does to the
world and I don't think there's a I
don't know how you get your handles on
around that in terms of constructing
models but I think we all have to be
more cognizant of the fact that the pace
of change and the things going on
outside our borders which we don't have
even less a clue about are really
important drivers of what happens here
mm-hmm well let's move on to the current
situation me now I look at my picture of
job loss in this current recession at
least once a month when I updated and
it's a pretty scary picture right now I
mean the pace a job destruction is still
probably as high as it's been since this
recession started and do you see a
catalyst for recovery here and you know
what's what's your sense of when the
economy turns around well I would like
to think that the worst is over and by
that I mean not not no more quarters of
negative six percent growth hopefully
not any more months of six and seven
hundred thousand job loss well housing
go another 30 25 to 30 percent down I
don't think so but all that means is
that the pace of contraction decreases
not that we're going to have
job creation anytime soon I think the
combination of the fact that our economy
adjusts rapidly compared to other
economies stimulus that's starting to
make its way through and all the other
things that the Fed has done to put a
cushion under things will put a brake on
some of this destructive stuff I think
it's possible that we have growth you
know GDP growth sooner rather than later
maybe I wouldn't think this quarter but
certainly next just because we have
responded with such alacrity we borrow
at very low rates and we're putting that
money to work in many ways so I think
you know likely this year we'll have
growth in GDP I don't know what that
means for jobs and housing and the
financial system i think you know i
don't think we have a banking problem
anymore more banks will fail the FDIC
handles those it handles them quite well
it nationalizes a bank for 10 minutes
and it places the deposits and the
branches with somebody else the banks
have paid into that fund it might get
drawn down but they can be replenished
over time we have a AIG and a citigroup
problem and those aren't getting any
easier to resolve so we have those
problems I think as far as getting out
of it you know we transition this is
sort of this whole we have this great
ability to latch onto new enthusiasms
technology and telecom and then when
that went bus we picked ourselves up and
started running after real estate i was
in credit and how's it so it's next we
need a you know the onion was the
satirical magazine said had a headline
no nation demands new bubble to invest
in so you know there was a period where
baby alternative energy was we that's
toyed with that but I think now I don't
you know if we had a sort of bubble or
boom in maybe efficiency or what I would
call the smart economy I think it would
be helpful I wouldn't get us out but it
would be
there's something to get enthusiastic
about and and where you start to see
some of that bubble mentality its
surrounding this and what I mean by that
is we had this alternative energy boom
and people are saying well you know we
do this for branding right makes people
think we're cool now the reason to do
alternative energy and efficiency is to
save you money right we all have the our
top line isn't growing at all mm-hmm
right as an economy as individuals as
businesses so you work on the bottom
line we all consume a lot of energy we
all can without you know we don't need
the whiz-bang technology to consume less
electricity heat gas etc we all it's
just a question of kind of behavior a
lot of this walmart has its experiment
where they built some green stores to
try to get yuppies to shop there yup
these are never going to shop at Walmart
the same time they said well can we
increase our fuel efficiency of our
truck fleet and they did it within a
year by fifteen percent not with any
great technology just filling the tires
or breaking etc that's worth hundreds of
millions of dollars to them every
company can do that right and so when
you see the fact that a lot of the
stimulus money you know if someone gave
me three thousand dollars spent on my
house a year ago or two years ago I
would have bought a new granite
countertop that's what everybody else
right now i might go buy some insulation
especially because they're all these new
tax breaks that the government is
subsidizing that type of activity now
you know say even get this kind of
advice at home Dan what don't tell me
that we're going to redefine like me
feeling good at 66 degrees is no wrong I
don't know you have to sacrifice the
koalas thing is it's things that don't
sacrifice the quality of life and so the
government they're going to they're
going to refurbish all their buildings
to make them more energy efficient there
are things you can do I think any other
question for economists is how much we
can get out of this right have some sort
of digitizing health records right a
drive for interested you know going from
this sort of dumb line to being smart
about the way we use resources I
aggrecan you by the way all kidding
aside I mean I think there is an element
of you know some savings to be had in
areas where we've come very inefficient
Society a lot of that stuff you know
imported energy right now if we can if
we can find our way off that that's its
own little stimulus package right so you
know I assume that you know the people
at mckinsey or maybe the National run
some numbers and saying if we had this
kind of nationwide drive for efficiency
in you know areas like energy in and you
see companies doing this instead of
business travel they're doing
teleconferences right when when economic
times are tough you start thinking about
do I need to spend this money and if
those sort of things can become a
permanent part of the way you operate
you've increased your margins right so
there is some amount I don't know what
percentage it is that we can kind of
increase our our efficiency and
operating income which will go along you
know it will certainly help in this
deleveraging process freeing up cash to
pay down debt consume spend I don't know
how long I'll Carter tried some of that
stuff I think but anyway I think we have
greater tools at our disposal to I think
we do that today no one I actually think
you know one of our problems as a
country is we haven't put a high enough
floor under gas prices from oil prices
to stimulate the kind of innovation that
I think you'd see in this country in a
high price regime and so you know we've
seeded a lot of that territory to other
countries that have higher taxes and I
think we could be a world leader in that
kind of innovation but it's just never
made sense because you haven't had
sustained high prices so you know to me
that's a double loss because if we're
taxing it we're discouraging consumption
is something that generates huge
negative externalities something we have
to import and then we're also not able
to get the market share we might get in
other countries with energy-efficient
products so but you know this imperative
you know companies are going through
this we're going through this and
Newsweek everywhere it's you have to
make do with less right you got to
either accept salary cuts or are any
faculty here to did everyone hear Dan we
have to make do with less companies are
polluted are you know you can use the
crude way of doing it which is to sort
of fire ten percent of it or shut
or you could try to propose in a more
holistic manner and say okay this is
everything we spend money on what sorts
of things can we do so that we're doing
what we do now but not spending and
consuming as a bunch of resources and
doing it I think that's an exercise that
pretty much every large company is going
through right now we'll see what kind of
results that yields this is inspiring
cancel the reservation at Magnus tonight
I think I've got some wheat thins at
your office Stanley anyway uh why don't
we why don't we turn it over for some
audience Q&A I would love to hear any
questions from the audience for Dan I
have more questions I could ask I don't
you should there we go oh let's see what
time we've got here we still have 20
minutes for audience questions I was
just wondering um going back to your
earlier ears giving your background in
history did you find yourself to
essentially teaching yourself a lot of
economic stuff that you're very familiar
with today like deducing it just from
reading or did you find yourself going
back to text books and trying to reteach
things that you didn't know I'd you
already know the stuff or no I mean that
you know the beauty of journalism is
that you learn on the job and that every
day you're learning something different
you get to call people up and you can
either feign ignorance or just be at you
say tell me about your business tell me
about your paper people are very happy
to talk about themselves so it's a you
just have to be open sort of to the
learning I think that you know if I had
taken more economics courses would
certain things have been a little easier
for me as I was going along probably but
you know especially with the internet
today I mean if you want to understand
and just kind of poke around in what
happens to unemployment rates and how
unemployment rates align with payroll
job numbers right which people do papers
out and you might have a whole lecture
about you can look at it and look at it
for 15 minutes and talk to someone and
you'll get a real education on it and
that becomes part of your tool set one
of the parts of my job when I was
running a column for The New York Times
and also writing for slate where you're
writing online and you're always
providing your readers with links and
you're you know part of what you're
doing is explaining but also sending
them to places so it's not like teaching
but it's you are kind of getting to know
a subject and then sharing not just sort
of saying something about it but
directing people to the best sources
that's part of what you're doing so you
figure out very quickly we're the best
data sources who are reliable people
that other people should be looking at
and that's a very kind of helpful part
of the process follow up how like
generally speaking how quantit like how
deep to go quantitatively when you're
when you're looking at the stuff are you
you also forgive me about if I don't not
familiar exactly with like I you
sometimes frustrated that you wish you
might have more quantitative ability or
yep proud you know it's when you think
about who your audience is which is you
know and you have this weird dynamic
where if you're riding online you could
be writing for the whole world is
anybody can read you online but when
you're writing for a publication you're
writing for those subscribers so in
Newsweek it's three million people
across America who are not may not be
schooled in the ins and outs of
economics so there the use of numbers is
you know your sort of telling stories
anecdotes things like that when you're
writing online and you have the greater
ability to kind of link to you know
academic papers if you want to read more
about this or I'm telling you what this
person said you want to read the whole
thing go here and it enables you to get
a little more in depth or here's a chart
I constructed showing you know this
company stock versus the sp500 you have
so much more leeway to do that online so
if you want to you know when you when
you're writing and it's very easy to get
bogged down because you want to say
unemployment was this much and this year
you know you're using up a lot of your
space just telling the numbers when you
have a just use links to do it you you
are able to cover more
ground and provide your reader with you
know as in-depth material as you want to
go but I'm not a quantitative you know I
would edit these articles by economists
and or all sorts of people and you'd get
these equations with Sigma's and Omega
is another Greek letter and you know the
important i owe de if it's a really good
paper and they've got a lot of notation
yet is not it i didn't need to know what
what that meant I needed to know what
their conclusion was and then and then
sort of helped them explain how they
were getting there yeah you know it's
interesting and you know please take the
microphone to another question but you
know the stern school book I mean it was
put together by 33 faculty members in to
stir in school it's chock full of data
and it covers you know the same story
that you're writing about in you know
pretty short volume with you know it's
easy to read but I I don't know I think
you probably arrive at many of the same
conclusions they do they probably
document the case for their points in a
more systematic fashion but you know I
think there's room for both of those
because as you pointed out earlier the
stern school book is not going to be you
know widely read it gets too technical
and it's a little bit dry i like it hi I
want to come back to something you said
earlier that I found pretty interesting
you almost advocated the abandonment of
economic ideology so my question to that
is with which with what lens do you view
the economy and economic policy it
almost sounds as if you know we're
entering something we've never been
through before we're through history
there's been credit cycles credit
bubbles expansion of the global economy
it almost sounds as if you're saying
it's different this time whereas
history's proved it's usually not yeah
that's a great question in which
economic ideology mean there was Marxism
and you know I supposed to go all right
I guess why i say ideology it's the not
being of much use well we have a
question about what should we do with
AIG right so libertarian says
Fremont I believe in the free market let
them fly them go okay well do you want
all the insurance companies and pension
funds and all these European banks to
fail to and there we are sure yeah if
you're in a position of responsibility
that can't be the answer okay and then
the other side of the economic ideology
yeah we can't be bad for your future
employment right now for policymakers
right knee you can't have to step in if
you if you if your job is if you were in
the White House policy shop you can't
have that attitude in this type of
crisis the people in the last
administration who were you know far
apart from the carnival they're
approaching it's sort of in a similar
way right which tells you something and
then the other extreme is well you know
Wall Street our financial system is
totally corrupt we need a much more kind
of government managed a type of
environment like they have in some other
countries well that doesn't do you much
good either because you know it won't
work here but it also it doesn't it
doesn't get us to where we want to be it
still doesn't tell you what to do with
see nationalized city okay then what
right run it like you know we'd be like
France where they nationalized banks we
don't want to do that we can't do that
do we just sell it off tomorrow to get
whatever price we can get well you know
we had this experience with continental
Illinois and the 80s it was the first
bank that was too big to fail and the
Reagan administration we nationalized it
we took eighty percent of the stock
ownership and over a six-year period
dribbled it back out into public
ownership and by the way so the cost to
the taxpayer was half what they thought
it would be because they had the
government had patient money and I was
done under Reagan you wouldn't have
thought Reagan nights would be doing
that so when you get into these crises
you know Nixon had the line about we're
all Keynesian now I just think it's very
you know as much as sort of cable TV
wants to put people up to say one thing
or the other for the people who are in
positions of authority and if you're
running a company it just doesn't it
just doesn't do to have a kind of
dogmatic ideological approach to it
maybe the reggae nights forgot they were
in government because they're running a
business
and you know as far as you know I happen
to think that the a lot of the economic
policy and the presumptions behind
policy of the last eight years which you
know I've found them to be kind of crude
you know cut taxes on capital and this
will happen you know you look at the
last 16 years we have a pretty good case
study we had eight years where taxes on
capital were high taxes on marginal
rates were high right and the economy
did really well and asset markets of all
kinds did really well so that was the
90s and people I've my first some of the
first stories I wrote was calling people
what will happen if Clinton raise taxes
in 1993 Oh will kill the economy well we
have the greatest peacetime expansion
history then we get new crowd comes in 0
1 208 and if you told ten economists 100
economists we're going to cut marginal
income tax rates cut capital gains cut
dividend rates be very friendly they
would have said oh the economy's going
to do really well stock markets going to
do really well well the economy didn't
do that well stock market produce no
essentially no return in eight years I
mean did okay through 07 but ended in
tears asset markets of all kinds have
done pretty poorly so what is the
conclusion from that that maybe these
tax changes don't matter that much
because there are all these other
factors going on or that maybe what you
thought about the impact of I think
people make way too much above taxes we
have them in a pretty narrow band here
so that Gordon 33 to 36 36 to 39 will
not have the same impact of going from
7250 or from 50 to 39 don't agree more
there's way too much emphasis on that
and there's way too much noise in these
other factors in the background I think
make it really hard to say well we cut
taxes and X happened over the next five
years I mean so many things besides
taxes so that's part of what i mean by
sort of you know losing some of the
ideology there's this pretty had been a
pretty broad consensus sort of in the
middle about where we are and then
you've got all these kind of new
players you know the behavioral
economists who are getting a lot of
attention and juice now well I think
have a lot of interesting things to say
because they can explain why a lot of
things that Orthodox economists would
tell you are supposed to happen don't
happen and this is the first
administration where there are
behavioral comments on the inside and
they are seeking Cass Sunstein and
they're much more versed in this and so
we're going to have an experiment as to
whether there's going to be some
applications of this right this is sort
of the next wave and that'll be
interesting to watch question yeah
comparisons between the Depression of
the 1930s in the current crisis there's
been a kind of out of hand dismissal of
over emphasizing that comparison by
referencing the twenty five percent
unemployment rate that existed during
the Great Depression but then I saw a
new story in rotors in January that
seems like it showed up and then
disappeared which is that in the 1960s
LBJ's administration actually changed
the way they count unemployment and that
if we today counted unemployment the
same way they did in the 1930s namely
including those who haven't yet been in
the market like unemployed graduating
seniors like myself or those who are
discouraged workers not looking for work
anymore if we actually still counted
them in the in the ranks of the
unemployed that this back in January so
before the last three months
unemployment was sitting the stories
that either 16.1 or 17.1 percent i can't
remember that but that at the time was
double what the official unemployment
was so given official unemployment has
gone up by however many percentage
points who knows how many more we're
actually looking at comparison counted
the same way a scientific approach 20
plus percent unemployment where is that
news story I've written about that what
you're talking about is if you go to the
BLS website the u6 right they give you
the headline number and then they have
all different level measures of kind of
labour market under util they call
alternative measures of labour market
under
ization so tell you how many people are
working part time but would really like
to be working full time how many people
got so discouraged they've left the
workforce how many people are you know
sir working two jobs things like that
and so then they total that up and so
that's the u6 number and that is they
started measuring that I believe in the
80s so we don't have it going all the
way back but I think the most recent
number was 15.6 so if you add up
frustrated job workers people who are
underemployed and marginally attached
the discouraged workers people working
part time for economic reasons IE they
would rather be working full time that
measure is up to fifteen percent now the
the data collection in the 30s was
suspect on many levels or some measures
of unemployment I gets pretty hard yet
didn't take into account works like in
the Civilian Conservation Corps in some
of those make-work jobs which were
actually real jobs but I don't know I I
as someone who is background is in
history I think the comparisons you know
it's an analogy but I don't think it's
anything like you know the dow fell
eighty or ninety percent in 1933 there
was no banking system Roosevelt declared
a bank holiday several thousand banks
failed there was no FDIC there was no
social security we had no safety net the
federal reserve was a immature
organization at that point that didn't
have any of the tools or the
capabilities so I think for a variety of
reasons the the analogy only goes so far
follow-up question about no I'm
graduating seniors collegehumor com did
a survey a few months ago that showed
that only twenty-seven percent of
graduating seniors this is a national
number actually had employment lined up
I'm a engineering student and we had
always high expectations for employment
after graduation and very few of my of
my classmates actually have jobs lined
up and in this context the Chancellor of
this University is attempting to raise
tuition with the justification that our
degrees worth something but given how
few of us can actually find work we're
not convinced I'll take that happily
well you know this is a bad time to hit
the the job market and I'll be the first
to acknowledge that and I'm someone who
graduated from college in the last
recession 8283 that people talk about in
relation to this one where unemployment
measured by today's standard peaked at
well over ten percent and so it was a
very similar job market to this one and
I can tell you that going out into the
world today with a college degree
especially from an institution this good
positions you far better than most
people to compete effectively secondly I
would say you're going out into a world
where lots of things as Dan was talking
about earlier housing the ability to buy
into the equity market all these things
are so much more affordable than they
were two years ago so in many respects
while it'll take longer to find your
first opportunity for most graduates it
will come and when it does your
generation your cohort that graduates
now is actually in a great position to
start building from there so while it's
hard to get that first job I don't think
it's necessarily the worst time to come
out into the labor market and when I
look back at the people i graduated from
undergrad with at uw-eau claire which is
a one of the system campus is not even
madison they've done remarkably well
over their careers in fact we get
together and pinch ourselves some time
and think you know how did people that
went to UW Eau Claire end up doing this
well they did great so you can't get too
caught up in the moment you know some of
the things we talked about earlier i
mean actually as bad as it is today over
the last 25 years the SP in real terms
is up to two hundred fifty percent it's
not you know it's not the end of the
world it's it's going to be a tough path
back you know and whether this is the
right time or the best time to raise
tuition in
I think the Chancellor is phasing in a
tuition increase over four years it
still leaves this school's tuition well
below other Big Ten institutions and I
think if you look at the outcomes of our
students by any metric that positions us
as a vastly better value than other
schools and it's a question of you know
do people want to invest in quality or
not and you know who should pay the tab
and it'd be nice if the state paid the
tab I personally think the biggest
beneficiary is the most fortunate people
in this state are people that get to go
to this university so I don't think
asking the median taxpayer in Wisconsin
to pay that marginal cost of quality is
fair I think asking those of us who
benefit most from it to shoulder more
the burden makes sense but you know
that's that's a value judgment and you
know we could go back and forth on that
but I think the state has invested a lot
in this university it's one of the best
public universities in the world can I
say that on big thing calm said I think
we have time for one more question and
then we wrap it up Shawn Cleary dan in
your opinion what was the government
role in the financial collapse and when
do you think that role actually came
into play you know there's been theory
that in the early 90s with the start of
the deregulatory push that that was it
98 with the Fannie and Freddie situation
that occurred then you know so back and
possibly even you know within the
Clinton administration and that regime
Bush and administration thereafter where
do you think the critical point was
where where the pervasiveness of the
attitude of what's gone on in the
environment related to the collapse
occurred and also along with that
separating the presidential
administrations to the actual Congress
itself how do you feel about how that
comes into play you know this is a I
don't focus that much on the sort of
regulatory and Washington in my book in
part because a friend of mine is doing a
book that's coming out in about two
months name is Barry Ritholtz the book
is called bailout nation
it focuses almost exclusively on the
role of the fed credit raters sec etc a
lot of blame to go around when my book
came out we did a dialogue on slate with
four or five other journalists a woman
from the Financial Times a guy from
portfolio magazine described Barry
Ritholtz someone from New York magazine
and one of the you know it's a sort of
online dialogue posing sort of the
counter factual question of was there a
point you know where this could have
been averted right we like to when
something happens and we do the sort of
archaeology and dig it up we assume that
the outcome was inevitable and so you
factor out you filter out the
information that doesn't comport with
that and you know what I learned in from
studying history was that you have to
look at at history as it unfolds as if
it's contingent in every moment the
people in World War two they didn't know
was going to end in 1945 they had no
inkling in when they were making
decisions and acting in 1943 how it was
going to turn out and so when you're
telling the story you have to try to
recreate that sentiment and the kind of
choices people faced so the question is
you know were there a moment where
somebody if they had done something
differently if they had flipped a
certain switch could have stopped this
and my general answer is you know when
we get bubbles going and they are as
much cultural social political
phenomenon as they are economic
phenomenon so the idea that one person
could stand up and say halt even someone
like Alan Greenspan I don't buy that but
there are certain moments where you say
if they had done something differently
maybe the fallout wouldn't have been so
bad so I look at the time I think was an
0 for when the CEOs are the five
investment banks go to the SEC and they
say your regulations require us and we
have brokerage firms and ask the matters
we can only leverage up 12 to 1 we'd
like you to change that so that we can
go higher up to 25 to 1 and the sec
there's a you know says okay and one of
the commissioner says I'm voting for
this with my fingers crossed now
if they had been preventative from going
they would have found other ways to do
they would have had off-balance sheet
vehicles and done other things but bear
stearns and lehman brothers would not
have gotten into the shape that they
were well that's one Greenspan was there
was a movement in the 90s to regulate
credit default swaps and derivatives and
this was during the Clinton
administration and Rubin and Greenspan
and some others put pressure on and
people in Congress who were doing the
bidding of the financial services
industry said no and they put a stop to
it Arthur Levitt who was the SEC
chairman is you know in retrospect is
saying that was a mistake of him not to
push harder so say if there had been
some regulation and transparency
surrounding that AIG might not have
happened Fannie and Freddie had
accounting problems in 04 and 05 and
they've been a there have been critics
of them going on for years and if
somebody had said these institutions
should only get so big and they should
do nothing else but by issue the
mortgages that they do and not by
mortgage-backed securities and not be
trading and not buying subprime loans
that might have stopped them so i don't
think it's sort of one thing even though
it was a systemic failure this system
was so large and had so many moving
parts that the notion that should have
throwing one sandbag in the hole would
have stopped the flood it with the flood
was and was coming from overseas and was
happening everywhere so but I think you
can point to sort of certain moments
that might have had a gone the other way
averted things happening the way they
did in certain in certain aspects well
it's a good lesson there never cross
your fingers when you vote just vote the
other way dan thank you very much thank
you
pleasure to have you with us